Let's keep solving equations. When we're doing that, we can add, we can
subtract, we can multiply, we can divide, or we can even do other operations.
But whatever we do, we have to keep one rule in mind. No matter what, we have to
do the same operation to both sides of the equation. If we don't do this, we're
going to change the initial relationship that we started out with between our
quantities. And the answer we get in the end, won't work with that equation.
Let's start out with a pretty simple example, x plus 3 equals 12. Then, I'm
going to draw two boxes down here, one for each side of the equation. And in
each box, I would like you to write what step you think should happen next, to
change either side of our equation, so we can eventually get x by itself.
For now though, we're just going to write this one step in. So, for example, if
you think that we should add 8 to the right-hand side, then write plus 8 in the
box on the right. Or if you think we should divide by 2 on the left-hand side,
please write a slash and 2, to symbolize divide by 2. Please remember that if
you want to symbolize multiplication, do not use an x, rather use the star
symbol and then, of course, whatever number you want.